[Music]
from the sublimely traditional
[Music]
to the aggressively avant-garde
[Music]
korean culture is having a moment at the
south by southwest festival koreans are
crazy about new stuff
and i think they're good at accepting
new environment and new policies new
culture
and i like that part of korean
so does everyone else apparently
the korean movie parasite won oscars for
best picture best director and best
screenplay in 2020.
[Music]
k-pop has millions of avid fans
worldwide and the blockbuster boy band
bts is one of the most popular acts in
the world
[Music]
[Applause]
the shocking hybrid horror and social
commentary series squid game became
must-see pandemic era tv
at the festival podcasters sarah lane
and melissa kim led a discussion on
korean tv's global appeal the story
lines are so interesting anyone can
relate to
like class inequality there's so much
great content coming out of korea
the korean culture boom came about not
by accident but as part of a deliberate
government strategy beginning in the
1990s explains global studies professor
yoon lee the korean government realized
that it's important for them to focus on
culture so more than 100 million dollars
were supported for korean culture
industry to support creative content
the effort has paid off not only in a
multi-billion dollar entertainment
industry but also in more intangible
ways
now
like a korean culture has become a
symbol of what
korean pride would be so
this is a way to make connections with
the world
while other countries focus on military
might and seek to dominate their
neighbors through force
korea chose soft power and its success
sends a powerful message
make music and movies not war
rob reynolds al jazeera austin texas